وللمزيد من التفاصيل الميدانيه ينضم الينا
من موسكو مراسل فرانس مازن صباح الخير
واهلا بك مازن ما هي اخر المستجدات فيما
يتعلق سواء بالهجوم بمسيره على موسكو او
فيما حصل بالهجوم على محطه نوويه او على
البلده التي تضم محطه نوويه بلده
البيانات الرسميه تعرضت بالفعل ضاحي موسكو
ايضا لهجوم المسيرات وايضا
بالاضافه ايضا
لمقاطعه
تعرضت ايضا لمحاولات هجوم بالمسيرات لكن
بحسب البيانات الرسميه فان هذه الهجمات قد
تم احباطها واسقطت هذه المسيرات من
الملاحظ بالتاكيد انها على مدار اليومين
الماضيين تعرضت نحو زماني مناطق في روسيا
الى هجمات مكثفه من جانب المسيرات
الاوكرانيه هذا الامر يستدبعه بالتاكيد
اجراءات كثيره يعني اليوم على سبيل المثال
تم تاجيل نحو 32 رحله طيران مدني جويه
والغاء 20 رحله من مطارين اساسيين في
موسكو هذه المسيرات تسبب بعض المشاكل وان
كانت لا تتمكن من تحقيق اهدافها في تدمير
المشاهات التي تستهدفها ولكن
القياده العسكريه الروسيه تتوقع ان تزداد
هذه الهجمات خلال فصل الشتاء وان تكون
موجهه لمنى التحتيه من محطات تمويل كهرباء
وخلود كهرباء
وانابيب تدفئه الى ذلك لذلك بدات بالفعل
القوات القياده على العسكريه الروسيه
بنشر المزيد من الرادارات ذات المجال الذي
يتراوح بين 60 الى 100 متر لتكون قادره
على رصد هذه الطائرات عندما تعبر الحدود
وتصل لمناطق المجال الرادارات الروسيه
وبالتالي اسقاط هذه الطائرات قبل ان تقترب
من اهدافها
شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلنا من موسكو مازن عباس